this [ __ ] hair right here i don't
know what this belongs my hair
what are you laughing at look at that
[ __ ]
this is beautiful you got rotini curls
this is beautiful beautiful this hair is
beautiful you look like i've had a
haircut look like patrick mahomes sister
patricia you look like sandy
i'm comedian ryan sickler and this is my
stepson derek crawford while we were on
quarantine class might have been out but
school was still in session all right
let's go
very serious business you have lives
especially this one
and your literal hands and feet
it was like an old country road and it
had an awesome hill to jump jumping them
yeah yeah do
[Music]
i mean jesus christ stay in your lane
you're hurting jerky with turns this is
learner's permit
let me get this guy right here
hey jeff
jeff
i can't believe that guy jumped he did
that guy joked oh he jumped he didn't
even know where it was come bro he's
looking all around his hands are in his
pocket yeah he's nervous and shocked you
remember that one time i did it and the
guy he went to went away
just heavy on the brakes man these will
glide into you know nice and easy are
you waiting for this biker right here
and well now you i mean jesus christ
like she's gonna be here in another
month i mean it's the perfect time to
learn how to drive but it's not
realistic to be honest not in l.a but
there's no one on the ship right now
three people
shot at us by now gave us the finger
cuss
[Music]
my first car was a toyota corolla tercel
and then they changed them one was a
corolla one but i was stoked man i got
it for 500.
damn we used to go to this place called
uh wards chapel it was like an old
country road and it had an awesome hill
to jump i mean awesome hell to jump
and we're talking about toyota station
wagons my car like people jumping them
yeah they do we jumped the [ __ ] out of
them and then everybody as soon as you
did though you busted your leaf springs
your your suspension your shocks will
blow out but we would jump the [ __ ] out
it's worth it and we got so good at
jumping these cars there were a couple
idiots that would lay under the hill and
i'm talking
and they did oh the cars will clear them
easy though that's crazy i was just like
you're [ __ ] we're gonna watch
somebody
but nobody ever did what do you want
your be your first car i've been saying
i wanted a honda civic one of the newer
ones like a 2017 or 2016. but i just
can't get over the the like the
speedometer and just the dash i don't
like it i don't like it it's just
there's something about it makes though
it just throws me off the whole car what
the hell are you talking hey
to get it in the groove i had only had
one mirror over that didn't even have a
mirror here and hell half the time
people had their rear view fall off you
know that's that's you're a good driver
if you can drive with only a side mirror
and no passenger and no rear view i
wouldn't drive with that car i wouldn't
trust myself in that you're going to
pass up on a car because of the design
of the dashboard i'd get it watch where
you're going stay in your lane you're
herky-jerky with turns all because of a
speedometer your 16 is way different
than my 16.
[Music]
my favorite car of all time was my 1990
honda civic with original rims it had oh
god i think it was like four thousand
five hundred miles on or something i put
like 175 or 180 000 on that thing i
drove it across the country three times
starting at the east coast starting
where 70 however you look at it begins
or ends in maryland all the way out my
buddy again eric snyder got all drunk
he's like i'm gonna go with you and when
he passed out we put him in the car he
woke up i stopped at his house got him a
couple clothes
and when he woke up we were we were west
of pittsburgh almost an indiana and he's
like where are we i was like we're
outside of pittsburgh what are you
talking about i'm like you said you
wanted to go so i drove that across went
all the way up the rocky mountains in a
honda civic i mean with everything i own
and it was blizzard it was a blizzard in
ohio they were making people sleep in
the shopping mall parking lots
i've never scraped ice off the inside of
my windshield except for that time only
drove out drove back drove out again
yeah
i lived in that little civic and then in
west texas on the way back the third
time i [ __ ] threw that ice scraper
right out the window
hey jeff jeff
[Music]
[Music]
you